I have will try having psoriasis I feel
bad for people that have diseases that
do you have an autoimmune disease there
the [ __ ] dermatologists are like well
yeah I can put you on this drug where
that's so strong you can't get life
insurance or here's a cream that doesn't
work shrug they don't know what to do
yeah if I was a doctor this is how much
doctor
yeah head I had the flu in that I got it
broke out like in my legs and stuff and
and the so this I'll be the
dermatologist okay I went to school okay
just start describing okay that's right
yeah so I got psoriasis I got the flu
and I broke out on my legs and all that
yeah so I don't know what to do
yeah well that's that's what happens
that don't happen I say it has gone away
for six months Lloyd the thing is is it
hasn't gone away for six months yeah
yeah that'll happen I guess you could
try son and oh that's what it isn't I'll
give you a steroidal cream don't you
overuse it just once a day I guess I
love when doctors say I guess this is
well a lot of doctors do a lot of times
this if I was a doctor yeah I want to do
it be a doctor and then [ __ ] you come
in and you say I've got a pain in my
side or something good I have a pain in
my side I [ __ ] that's my doctor
advice with a D how about I didn't have
a pain in my side mm-hmm like on my side
and I was like so I go to the doctor and
I'm like this doesn't make sense why
would I have a pain why would a one pain
in my sinus doesn't make sense
to a doctor he does all these tests he
goes well your blood your blood work is
pretty outstanding liver functions great
so because I'll send him down the
surgeon I said I think I have a hernia
hello so I go to this surgeon he's like
this
I'm cedars-sinai seen it all he's like
50 I go I think I haven't hernia and he
goes you do and I go yeah he goes where
is it again ago right here and he goes
hmm that's interesting I know why I
guess no it's kind of fascinating I know
it is and he goes well it is in the
sense that you'd be the only person in
history to have a hernia there oh that's
impossible and then I go oh and he goes
now I know your next question is is that
pain something ominous and I go that is
my next question he goes no it's not no
that's not how things work I think what
you did is tore the lining on the inside
of your stomach which is why your doctor
said right
yeah and he goes okay so you can get out
of my office now oh this is so funny
I was like okay bye-bye sometimes a cop
an attitude though you know yeah like
alright what I got to do I got a [ __ ]
you know I had I had a like a [ __ ]
fissure in my butthole
you know what I mean oh yeah yeah
because you don't drink enough water
well are you [ __ ] no that's not it
dude that's the rumor so and the doc was
like I felt like the doctors like I can
look in your butt oh god I mean such a
pain in the ass yeah
hey how about putting a suppository in
your butt though never done it what
really yeah why do it when I was a baby
when you do it
let me tell you something man for the
people out there that I've put in
medicine in there Bob why did you have
to put us a positive the [ __ ] vision
I mean I was like 22 or something so I
got a few years ago why would I would
have a suppository help your fever
because it it's a cut in there oh inside
yeah so you had to put yeah the the
suppository in there Wow bro I was so
nervous doing it and then you do it it
feels [ __ ] amazing dude you go like
this it's so you know what it is
soothing okay I don't know yeah well you
don't know well when you do know you're
gonna call me up dude I won't get there
call me I'll get to be my age the doctor
sticks his finger up your ass and feels
your prostate gland and then every time
he does he goes flat as a pancake what
does that mean oh it's good but I don't
like that I don't like when he loses a
finger in your rump so don't you have to
do that when you're 40 or something like
that yeah you start you start that
before I've had have you ever had a girl
stick of no their nose I don't like that
I'm not crazy if I had III I mean I've
had girls like ask and want to do it and
I'm like nah nah yeah I'm not into ass
nah nah neither am i I don't even like
necessarily doing it to a girl like I
don't really care yeah it's not that
like I'm grossed out I'm just like who
cares yeah right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue Oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[ __ ]